hello everyone
a few days ago i penned an irritated
tweet
in response to one of the latest
happenings on the increasingly heated
culture war front
in response to the decision of an
actress
actor named ellen
elliot page
i am employing this awkward and
impossible naming style
because it is now apparently mandatory
and probably doing it wrong
nonetheless as you're doing it wrong is
the whole point of what has been made
mandatory but also i'm trying to make a
point
i've essentially been banned from
twitter
as a consequence
i say banned
although technically i have been
suspended but the suspension will not be
lifted unless i delete the hateful tweet
in question and i would rather die than
do that
and hopefully it will not come to that
although who the hell knows in these
increasingly strange days
what was it that i said
that caused such a fuss
and that fuss is just
beginning and even more importantly and
complexly what exactly was it that i
said
that resulted in the ban
here's the tweet in question
remember when pride was a sin
and ellen page
just had her breasts removed
by a criminal physician
then a link to a story that detailed out
the
happenings the response from twitter
quote
violating our rules against hateful
conduct
you may not promote violence against
threaten or harass other people on the
basis of race ethnicity national origin
sexual orientation gender gender
identity religious affiliation age
disability or serious disease
by clicking delete
you acknowledge that your tweet violated
the twitter rules delete
if you think we've made a mistake
submit an appeal to us please note that
should you do so your account will
remain locked while we review
your appeal
let's take this apart
first
it is clearly the case that i did not
promote violence against
or threaten
anyone with my missive
so that leaves the arguably lesser sin
of harass
let's assume
since i wasn't informed that that was
the crime
and further harassment on the basis of
so-called gender identity sits twitter
did not do me the favor of actually
specifying my crime and there are many
possibilities on that front we
unfortunately have to guess at why this
has occurred and that's actually a big
problem in and of itself and also
indicative of the utter carelessness of
the twitter organization with regard to
the propriety of its own sensorial
actions
i should at least know exactly what i
did wrong
if i am required to acknowledge that my
tweet violated the twitter rules
what rules you sons of [ __ ] exactly
precisely
because such things matter when the
accusations start flying
so what did i say that might constitute
harassment
well many things hypothetically let's
begin with
remember when pride
was a sin
although that is merely a factual
statement because under the old rules
applicable even a decade ago pride
was a sin
and had been recognized as perhaps the
cardinal sin for thousands of years
previously
it still might be regarded as
unacceptable to the woke authoritarian
moralists who now insist for example
that we celebrate
pride month not hour or day or week but
month
and to have literally called it pride
month
instead of lgbt plus month or whatever
else alphabet acronym which is currently
insisted upon as the only acceptable
enlightened terminology
i don't regard pride as a virtue it has
been classically regarded as a sin i
don't see that sexual orientation or
sexual desire of any sort is something
to celebrate or to take pride in and so
what i said was merely a fact now it's
possible that i hurt someone's feelings
because i pointed out that pride goes
before for example a fall
but i don't care about that
would do it again
and also consider it my duty to warn
those who are about to fall into a pit
that the path they are on leads suddenly
downhill
but that was probably not the reason
that i was banned from twitter although
as i said i am in the position
of having to guess
next phrase to interrogate
and ellen page
now why did i stop there
because in all
likelihood it was this seemingly
innocuous phrase
including the name
of a well-known actress there i'm in
trouble again
that likely resulted in my ban i
committed the fatal crime of what has
come to be known in the appalling
sensorial terminology of the insane
activists as dead naming which is the
act of referring to someone who has
transitioned another hated piece of
jargon and slogan by the name and by the
inference the gender
really the sex that everyone knew them
by previously and in the case of ellen
slash elliott that millions of people
recognized and knew
so i should have either called him her
they elliot instead of ellen
although as we will discover that would
have made it impossible for me to say
what i wanted to and need to say in the
remaining phrases not that such a
problem would bother those who are
objecting to my speech in the first
place
the next phrase is
just had her breasts removed
this bit suffers
from a very similar problem
i employed the forbidden pronoun her
when elliot ellen is now to be regarded
as a he
or else
but there's a conundrum here to say the
least and not just for me although i
have been banned because of it was
elliot slash ellen a she
or a he
or ellen or elliot when she or he or
they that's elliot or alien by the way
had his or her or their breasts removed
if he or she was a he
then why was it necessary to have the
mastectomy
and how could those i'm writing to make
sense of what i was saying if it was his
breasts that were removed
were those male breasts or female
breasts that were removed
if they were male breasts
then why were they removed
if they were female breasts and had
therefore become objectionable to the
degree that surgery generally reserved
for cancer treatment was required was
morally obligatory then wasn't eliot
still ellen and he still she
how could i possibly have written that
sentence in any sensible manner
whatsoever
while simultaneously making my point
understandably and not breaking twitter
rules against
so-called
hateful conduct
and
eliot page just had his breasts removed
was he elliot then
when exactly exactly
he was definitely ellen at some point in
the past
or so indicate all his her them their
film credits
will all those have to be re-shot since
they employed the hated dead name that
doesn't exist by the way that dead name
category except in the sensorial and
adult minds of a tiny fraction of
insanely narcissistic and increasingly
dangerous trans activists
when precisely was it incumbent on me to
switch my terminology in regard to
elliot slash ellen
so that i was not engaging in hateful
conduct
and how can i describe the fact that
someone who was once a woman and really
still is had her breasts cut off because
she he they their them had fallen prey
to a viciously harmful fad
without using the appropriate sex link
pronoun and the real name of the real
person to whom this was
really done with his her their voluntary
but unfortunate acquiescence and so it
was impossible to communicate what had
happened
to my audience without apparently
running afoul of the impossible and
observed rules that now hypothetically
govern morality itself in the days of
the degenerated postmodern and marxist
ethos that we must still no matter how
impossible it is abide by or else
and you might object alan slash elliott
is an adult 30-something and fully
capable of making up his her their own
mind about such things and she he they
are welcome from the liberal and the
libertarian position to go to hell in a
handbasket as she he they
see fit
and fair enough to some degree
but i don't believe it is either merely
picayune or inappropriate to point out
that ellen slash elliot who is quite a
good actor slash actress
is also a ritual model
for emulation
being a star with all the privileges and
let us point out the responsibilities
that go along with that so by
acquiescing to this surgery and by
publicizing it by insisting upon the
sanctity and the moral virtue of his her
their new expensive dangerous and
medically enhanced identity and by
participating in the whole identity
sharad
alan elliott has undoubtedly with his
her their so-called courage and remember
the white house itself has tweeted out
every indication of believing in the
courage of those who transition
enticed many a poor confused adolescent
girl most likely to blame her emergent
pubescent self-consciousness confusion
and discomfort on being born in the
wrong body and believing that the
courageous self-affirming and morally
admirable root is hormonal treatment
sterilization subjugation to a lifetime
of expensive medical complication how
delightfully profitable is that and
misery
and i believe firmly that ellen slash
elliot or whatever the hell her name or
his name is bears
moral culpability for that
and finally
with regard to the final phrase
criminal physician i must say that i've
had some post-coital so to speak regrets
about that phrase
it is clearly the case that the surgical
operation performed by the butchers who
butchered elliott
ellen was legal
so was it criminal
or not
were the operations undertaken by the
fascist physicians who carried out the
nazi medical experiments legal
yes
under the laws of the time
but were they criminal
i'll leave that question up to you to
answer
and further
perhaps it might be objected
what about the damage done by
hypothetically leaving those confused
about their identity to dwell in their
confusion aren't we morally obliged to
intervene
and i would say
no
why
well
first
do no harm
as the hippocratic oath remember that
insists
and second
it has been a matter of historical
consensus
that sins of omission are less egregious
than sins of commission
thus
leaving someone with gender dysphoria no
matter how warranted and perhaps it is
in a very tiny minority of truly
unfortunate cases
to suffer the consequences of the
theoretical mismatch between soul and
body
is less of a risk ethically personally
socially and philosophically
than the extremely active intervention
that constitutes so-called gender
confirming another hated phrase surgery
i might also point out
that the trans surgery enterprise
is now a 300 million dollar per annum
growth industry rate of projected
expansion 15 per year projected increase
by 2027 to 750 million dollars per year
an expanding enterprise in a time of
global uncertainty time to invest both
in the requisite surgical skills and
perhaps in any industry associated with
this vicious and unconscionable fad
primarily entangling as such things so
often do the youthful
and female
isn't that a concern
intersectionalists
not when push comes to shove
or ideology to scalpel
is that not a true moral hazard
and i'm not taking down that tweet or
acknowledging that my tweet violated the
twitter rules
up yours woke moralists
we'll see who cancels who twitter's a
rat hole in the final analysis and i
have probably contributed to that while
trying to use understand and master that
horrible toxic platform
no doubt i owe some apologies for that
and i'm trying to learn but it's a
relief in some real sense to be banned
and i regard it under the present
conditions as a badge of honor